na ja und das ist langweilig hey leute
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
texture pack vorstellung heute stelle
ich euch dass es notwendig schipek vor
ich glaube so heißt das wenn wechsel
immer ganz kurz die ansichten und das
erste was ihr seht her wo ist die alte
decke geschossen
ja ich habe mir eine neue gedownloadet
von kerbala heißt diese map da braucht
jetzt gar nicht schreiben hilfe für
folge claudia die zum download angegeben
auf netzwelt zb also die haben die und
allgemein packe ich euch ein
download-link in die beschreibung
ich fand die welt einfach viel cooler
weil ihr seht hier erstmal einen
überblick über alle items und dann seht
ihr hier ist ganz groß alles aufgebaut
was damit zusammenhängt also mit diesem
texture pack alle blöcke einfach
aufgezählt in ein paar kombinationen
hier seht ihr erstmal ein rundum weg ist
es ein 16 16 texture pack das seht ihr
zum beispiel ganz gut bei diesen ärzten
ich finde ich werde das in den
zukünftigen videos nur noch benutzen nur
noch dieses special pack weil ich das
einfach so genial finde wenn ich wollte
das benutze dann mir egal ich finde es
genial ich finde es einfach nur schön
hammer und ich würde sagen wir gehen ja
einfach mal direkt runter und zwar
müssen werde ich einen kleinen schacht
wo wir ein paar eine kleine höhle haben
sage ich mal müssen wir hin durch paar
schilder und dann sehen wir auch hier
schon direkt ein mushroom biom also hier
sind ein paar blöcke aufgezählt wie zb
hier ein giant braun mushroom hier ein
großer roter mushroom also finde ich
sehr genial gestaltet dieses ding ist
weil es einfach klinik ist nicht so
deftige farben sondern echt wieder muss
sagen nicht triste farben sondern schon
ein wenig ein wenig weißlicher sag ich
mal wenig greulich hat das finde ich
schön hier auch das bird biom finde ich
allgemein hier die links finde ich sehr
schön die finde ich so ein bisschen ja
keine ahnung erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an
an götterspeise sage ich mal einfach
also finde ich sehr schön so
landschaften hier wenn man da so einen
coup ich sehr schön hier habt ihr ein
paar items die könnt ihr euch aber auch
selber angucken ein bisschen könne nicht
alles selber angucken also hier seht ihr
die items auf alle ein bisschen wie
pixel ich kann einfach was in der hand
nehmen hier zum beispiel so ein schwert
oder so also seht ihr schon 16 mal 16
pixel und ja ich würde sagen wir fangen
dann erstmal hier hinten an
was wir hier hier haben wir mops das
heißt da geh ich mal ganz kurz rein so
wir sehen hier erst mal kühe die gucken
ganz interessant guckt sich mallorca
die spielen hier eine scharfe waffe die
haben für schweine die schielen auch
aber ein wenig anders
villiger finde ich sehr interessant mit
diesem kopf route ab
ganz kurz weiter so dann haben wir hier
war so heftig an
schneemänner haben wir hier da haben wir
die pilz kühe sind genauso wie anderen
kühen nur halt ein bisschen verändert
hier haben wir schicken
und hier haben wir wölfe als jetzt fragt
euch bestimmt hervorkommen ganz anderen
sonst richtig dass in die monster hallo
monster davon war hier hinten an
so fängt an mit dem täter der ein
maskierter keine ahnung sich aus diesem
taliban oder so dann habe ich jetzt zum
biest das weiß nicht ob das nur an
meinem texture pack so ist aber
irgendwie haben die bei mir keinen
körper kann auch sein dass ich irgendwie
nicht richtig gedownloadet hab jetzt
habe ich hier auf einmal nachricht
bekommen haben wir spinnen
hier haben wir eigentlich sind die
skelette aber irgendwie sind noch keine
gespannt wir schauen einfach gleich
nochmal vorbei wenn die lust haben zu
bauen
hier haben wir noch nichts drin da kann
ich vielleicht nachher noch irgendwelche
neuen mops reinsetzen hier haben wir ja
was land der ist ziemlich groß dieser
ziemlich laut dmb ändern wenn auch sehr
interessant erinnert mich sehr an die
die volltexte textur hier haben wir
silberfische slams ich gehe das jetzt
ein bisschen schneller durch caves
beides also höhen spinnen hier diese
zombie pigments leiser
place place trotz nebels teile sind auf
jeden fall sehr geil wenn man experience
farmville uhr und hier haben wir einfach
nur noch ein paar kann man wo ich später
auch noch ein paar mops reintun werde
die dann in die neue hinzugefügt werden
wie zum beispiel hexen usw
allerdings ist dieses heck speck halt
also die hexen und so die kamen durch
den neuen snapshot hinzu und dafür ist
dieses text halt nicht draußen also es
1.3.1 jetzt gehen wir mal ganz kurz nach
oben dann zeige ich euch dann noch ein
paar items so möchte das alles relativ
schnell halten wir für euch halt ein
bisschen blöd ist wenn ich einfach mal
durchlaufen mit den anderson mit demenz
betten boote kekse kuchen paar also
fackeln pa natürlich natur sachen einen
drachen dann haben wir hier die irons
blass und so weiter halt so ein paar
sachen wie zum beispiel die hier alle
aus dem netz denn netter sieht allgemein
sogar los mit diesem briggs weil den
fand ich sonst mal total schrecklich
japan nutzt gegenstände wie zb öfen
crafting table braunstein champion table
tnt ein sehr schöner gegenstand hier ein
paar ärzte und wie sie dann in blöcken
aussehen also wie zum beispiel gold
eisen und so weiter hier so sachen die
man kann man ein bisschen reinsetzen ein
bisschen rum fahren kompliziert und und
und das ist langweilig übrigens habe ich
so ein komisches kindern bei minecraft
net.de hier am verschaltungen wenn
redstone aktiviert und deaktiviert das
haben die pisten sind alle möglichen
kombinationen können wir ein und
ausfahren hier wasser lawa und so weiter
moment wo waren wir dann hier ja so ein
paar natürliche sachen wieder also wie
zb pilze zuckerrohr weizen weizen finde
ich komisch wenn man sieht nicht die ob
die vorletzte oder die letzte
entwicklungsstufe gerade der verletzt
also das finde ich ein bisschen doof
hier erde finde ich allgemein aller
guides vom kompletten text weil es
einfach so dieses ja ich mag halt total
auf die spots mutig aber ich finds halt
einfach genial
jetzt kann man sehr schön durch gucken
andere sachen wie zb sein fenster und
oder mit schnee oder diesem museum dann
haben wir die holzsorten bzw holz
gegenstände oder die bäume finde ich
auch sehr schön gemacht dass hier unten
naja ich fast wieder zu viel über die
map anstellt weiß texture pack hierbei
den stein sehen wir auch zwischendurch
sind echt sehr unterschiedlich was man
hier bei coupies ton und den osten sieht
diesen wir beim gefreut nicht so
unterschiedliche allerdings schon
hier haben wir so bedrock oxidieren das
finde ich mit ist so die geilste textur
von allen weil man da wirklich so dieses
platzes mutige sieht und die haben jetzt
noch die komplette wolle da fliege ich
mal ganz kurz darüber könnt ihr euch
alle gucken was erstmal mit den
kompletten reinigt ob demnächst werde
ich einfach nur noch durchgehen und das
aufnehmen bisschen musik hinterlegen
jetzt noch ein paar teams aber komisch
wenn wir noch so ein paar häuser gebaut
so ein paar kombination wie das
vielleicht aussehen könnte ein paar
farben haben wir auch noch ein haus also
sind jetzt noch fünf häuser so sieht
fast genauso aus dies sieht auch ein
wenig ähnlich außer ist bisschen bis ein
bisschen klein
hier waren wir noch einen schönen keller
drin so der in eine höhle mündet das
heißt ihr seht ihr jetzt auch wie lava
aus sieht alles also alles in aktion das
und diamant erz und alles ist ganz schön
gestaltet er setzt auf die map bezogen
einfach nur damit ihr seht die neue
apple die neue action pack web ist echt
besser da haben wir noch eine ok fall so
wird das was ich gerade gezeigt hat wo
man noch die chance sein kann
hier haben wir die bilder also finde ich
sehr interessant weil einfach alles
gepixelt ist wir haben jetzt nicht sogar
hochauflösende bilder wo man nicht
erkennt sondern man sich einfach da sind
ein paar landschaften hat mich ein
bisschen an terraria finde ich sehr
interessant auf jeden fall hier geht es
wieder runter zu den monstern waren wir
auch schon hier sind noch so ein paar
häuser da geht frau wieder runter
irgendwohin
hier ist auch noch ein sehr schönes haus
des aller geisterhaus finde ich diese
sachen hier sollen fenster sollen
fenster darstellen die man auf und
zumachen kann singen wir sie so leiden
naja ablagen irgendwie sowas ist somit
eines der coolsten häuser waltz hat alt
einen keller hier unten wie ihr seht
also ein wirklich sehr großen keller
so weiter weiter weiter ich möchte euch
dass ihr uns noch zeigen so hier kommt
endlich wieder zu den dingen zu den
flops so hier kann man wieder hoch
fliegen moment bin nach oben
und auch wenn man hier nach oben geht
hat man ja nur halt noch eine zweite
etage noch relativ leer ist aber man hat
halt einen schönen überblick über alles
und ich würde sagen dass war es auch
damit dieser text schmeckt vorstellung
von es nun sich als notwendig speck was
ich bald verwenden werde
ab nun in allen meinen videos verwenden
werde du kennst schauen muss ich mal
gucken hier noch mal einen ausblick auf
die ganzen alters und dann würde ich
sagen ich will mich über einen daumen
hoch freue mich dass wir die gefallen
hat schreibt mir noch einen kommentar
das bett brennt ab und ja noch einen
schönen tag